There is a statue in South Carolina honoring a man who is known as the father of modern gynecology. The inscription on the statue reads, the first surgeon of the ages in ministry to women treating a like, Empress and slave. J. Marion Sims was a physician who was born in South Carolina in 1813. in South Carolina in 1813. This is Vanessa Northington Gamble. She's a physician and medical historian at the George Washington University. We asked her to come in to tell us the story
南卡罗来纳州有一座雕像，是为了纪念一位被称为现代妇科之父的人。雕像上的铭文写着：“时代的首席外科医生，致力于妇女治疗，不论是女皇还是奴隶。”J·马里恩·西姆斯是一位医生，1813年出生于南卡罗来纳州。这位是瓦妮萨·诺灵顿·甘布尔。她是乔治华盛顿大学的医师和医学史学家。我们邀请她来给我们讲述这段故事。
of Jay Marion Sims, who is memorialized in statues not only in South Carolina, but also in Montgomery, Alabama, and Central Park in New York City. He started a clinic in Montgomery, Alabama, and at the time, in order to survive financially, he also was a plantation physician, where he took care of the enslaved one plantations. This is where the story of Sims becomes complicated. Because, yes, the inscription on a statue in South Carolina is true.
关于杰伊·马里恩·西姆斯的历史，他的雕像不仅立在南卡罗来纳州，还立在阿拉巴马州的蒙哥马利以及纽约市的中央公园。他在阿拉巴马州的蒙哥马利开办了一家诊所，当时为了在财务上生存下去，他同时也是一名种植园医生，负责照顾种植园里的奴隶。正是在这里，西姆斯的故事变得复杂起来。因为，是的，南卡罗来纳州雕像上的铭文是真实的。
He did invent techniques that help women to this day. He treated slaves as well as high society. He once treated Empress Eugenie, the last Empress of France. But there is something not mentioned on the inscriptions on the statues. Starting in 1845, he started to conduct experiments on enslaved women. And why we talk about Sims today and why that statue was there is that he perfected a technique to repair a condition called vesico-vaginal fistja. And let me tell you what that means. It basically means that there is an opening between the vagina and also the bladder
他确实发明了至今仍能帮助女性的技术。他既为奴隶治病，也为上流社会治病。他曾为法国最后一位皇后欧仁妮治过病。但雕像铭文上没有提到一些事情。从1845年开始，他开始对被奴役的女性进行人体实验。我们今天谈论西姆斯的原因以及那座雕像之所以存在，是因为他完善了一种修复膀胱阴道瘘的技术。让我告诉你这意味着什么。这基本上意味着阴道和膀胱之间有一个开口，
or the vagina and the rectum, which usually comes after traumatic childbirth. And sims started in 1845, 1846, according to some sources, a series of experiments to repair these fistulas. This condition was highly stigmatized and dangerous for these women. There was no treatment. So on the one hand, you could say sims was doing what doctors are supposed to do by taking
或者阴道和直肠之间，通常发生在创伤性分娩之后。根据一些资料，西姆斯在1845年、1846年开始了一系列修复这些瘘管的实验。这种疾病对这些女性来说带有极高的污名且十分危险。当时没有治疗方法。所以一方面，你可以说西姆斯在做医生应该做的事，那就是接受
these women on his patients. But there's another side to what sims did. He wanted to be a trailblazing researcher, and these women, their bodies, became props in his journey of scientific discovery. These women were property. These women could not consent. These women also had value to the slaveholders for production and reproduction. How much work they could do in the fields, how many enslaved children they could produce, and by having these fisculas, they could not continue with childbirth,
这些女性作为他的病人。但西姆斯的所作所为还有另一面。他想成为一名开创性的研究人员，而这些女性的身体成为了他科学探索旅程中的道具。这些女性是财产。这些女性无法同意。这些女性对奴隶主来说也具有生产和繁殖的价值。她们能在田里干多少活，能生多少被奴役的孩子，而由于患有这些瘘管，她们无法继续生育，
and also have difficulty working. There are ten slave women central to the story. Three are named by Sims in his writing. These women were brought to him by their owners. The first woman was named Anarka. Anarka was a 17-year-old enslaved woman who had just undergone a very traumatic delivery. Some sources say that she was in labor for three days. At first, he did not want to treat her. He was not interested in treating women, but then what he started to do from a period from 1845 to 1849, he did a series of experimental surgeries on these women. And he uses sutures to try to close up this opening. Now presumably this would have been painful.
也难以工作。有十名女奴隶是这个故事的核心。西姆斯在他的著作中提到了其中三人的名字。这些女性是由她们的主人带给他的。第一个女性名叫安娜卡。安娜卡是一名17岁的被奴役女性，刚刚经历了一次非常痛苦的分娩。一些资料说她分娩持续了三天。起初，他不想治疗她。他对治疗女性不感兴趣，但随后在1845年至1849年期间，他开始对这些女性进行了一系列实验性手术。他使用缝合线试图缝合这个开口。现在想来这应该是痛苦的。
It was very painful and he talks about how Lucy, one of the three women, almost felt as if she were going to die, that she cried out and paying so much because of these surgeries. But at the same time, he writes that the women wanted the surgery because they did not want to have the condition anymore. Were the surgeries that he was performing on them performed without anesthesia? They were performed without anesthesia. There was a belief at the time that black people did not feel pain in the same way. They were not vulnerable to pain, especially black women, so that they had suffered pain in other parts of their lives, and their pain was ignored.
这非常痛苦，他谈到露易丝（三个女性中的一个）几乎感觉自己快要死了，由于这些手术，她大声哭泣并承受着巨大的痛苦。但与此同时，他写道，这些女性希望做手术，因为她们不想再患有这种疾病了。他给她们做的手术是在没有麻醉的情况下进行的吗？它们是在没有麻醉的情况下进行的。当时的观点认为黑人不会以同样的方式感到疼痛。她们对疼痛不敏感，尤其是黑人女性，因此她们在生活其他部分受到的痛苦被忽视了。
As Sims' reputation as a researcher grew, he began to invite other physicians to come watch as he performed the surgeries. So this surgery was done where black women were naked. So when we think about it, I think we think about pain, we also need to think about how these women's dignity were also taken away from them. For a long time, the surgeries didn't work. Now he's not successful at the beginning, and so that's why these surgeries went on from 1846 to 1849 and finally after 30 surgeries on one woman, he was finally able to perfect
随着西姆斯作为研究人员的名声越来越大，他开始邀请其他医生来看他做手术。所以这个手术是在黑人女性赤身裸体的情况下进行的。所以当我们回想时，我认为我们在考虑疼痛的同时，也需要考虑这些女性的尊严是如何被剥夺的。很长一段时间里，手术都没有成功。现在他一开始并不成功，所以这些手术从1846年持续到1849年，最后在一个女性身上做了30次手术后，他终于能够完善
his technique. That woman was Anika. The two others who are named in Simpsons' papers are Betsy and Lucy. I asked Vinesa Gamble whether there was any way to know if these women actually wanted the surgeries. We do not know that. The only thing we know is that Sim said that these women, one of the women, clamorously wanted to have the surgery.
他的技术。那个女性是安娜卡。西姆斯论文中提到的另外两个名字是贝茨和露易丝。我问维妮萨·甘布尔，有没有办法知道这些女性是否真的想要这些手术。我们并不知道。我们唯一知道的是西姆斯说这些女性中有一个人强烈要求做手术。
They wanted to be cured. One of the things in the story that's missing are the words and voices of the women themselves, not being translated by Sims. Sims of course has a self-interested reason to say that the women wanted what he was trying to do to them. Of course he has an interest. And one of the interests is that it mutes the story of slavery in his work, that it mutes the story that the foundations of modern gynecology are based on the body and the pain of enslaved black women.
她们想要被治愈。这个故事中缺失的一部分是女性自己的话语和声音，而不是由西姆斯翻译的声音。西姆斯当然有出于自身利益的理由去说女性希望他对她们做他试图做的事。他当然有利益诉求。其中一个利益在于，这淡化了在他工作中的奴隶制故事，淡化了现代妇科的基石是建立在被奴役黑人女性的身体和痛苦之上的这一事实。
The Statue of South Carolina that says that Sims treated Empress and slave women alike. Is that true? Was he treating white women the same way? He did treat white women, but he treated white women with anesthesia. Sims left in the 1850s. He left Alabama and moved to New York City for health reasons. And he started a woman's hospital in 1855 there. He gained a reputation as an excellent surgeon and so that he did treat white women. But the technique had been perfected on the bodies of black women. When you hear about a story that took place 150 years ago, there is a part of us that says that was pretty awful,
南卡罗来纳州的雕像说西姆斯对女皇和女奴一视同仁。这是真的吗？他对待白人女性也是一样的吗？他确实治疗了白人女性，但他用麻醉剂治疗白人女性。西姆斯在18世纪50年代离开了。他离开阿拉巴马州搬到纽约市是为了健康原因。他在那里于1855年开办了一家妇女医院。他获得了优秀外科医生的声誉，因此他确实治疗了白人女性。但这项技术是在黑人女性的身体上完善的。当你听到一个发生在150年前的故事时，我们内心的一部分会觉得这太可怕了，
but that was then, and this is now. But a lot of your work has actually tried to broaden that idea and said, yes, that was then, but some of what was then is also with us now. Right. I mean, one of the things that I teach a course on the history of race and racism in American medicine. And one of the things that I try to get across to my students is that racism is a very flexible, very adaptive concept. That yes, black people are not thrown out of hospitals these days because they are black or not excluded from hospitals because they are black. But our focus today is on what happens once one gets into the hospital.
但那是过去，而现在是现在。但你的许多工作实际上试图拓宽这种观点，并说，是的，那是过去，但过去的一部分也与我们同在。对的。我的意思是，我教的一门课是关于美国医学中种族和种族主义的历史。我试图向我的学生传达的一点是，种族主义是一个非常灵活、非常适应性强的概念。是的，黑人今天不会因为是黑人而被扔出医院，也不会因为是黑人而被排斥在医院之外。但我们今天的重点是一旦进入医院会发生什么。
It's striking as you say this because I feel like I've read studies in the last few years looking at disparities in how people of color get treated for pain in the late 20th century and the early 21st century. It feels like there is a thread between what happened 150 years ago and what's happening today. Right, I agree with you. I mean, because I think part of this story has to deal with how black bodies are conceptualized by the medical profession. There is a video that Johns Hopkins put out about people with sickle cell disease.
当你说出这些时这令人震惊，因为我觉得在过去几年里我读过一些研究，探讨有色人种在20世纪末和21世纪初在疼痛治疗方面受到的待遇差异。感觉150年前发生的事情与今天发生的事情之间存在着某种联系。是的，我同意你的观点。我的意思是，因为我认为这个故事的一部分与医学界如何概念化黑人身体有关。约翰霍普金斯大学制作了一段关于镰状细胞贫血症患者的视频。
And in this video, this woman woman says when I go to the hospital even though I'm in pain I make sure I get dressed up because if I get dressed up maybe I will be treated better and not be seen as somebody who is seeking drugs. So it still is there in terms of how the medical profession views black people and black bodies. It is true though that some of the things that Marion Sims discovered are still being used or in form medical practice today. Yes. He went on to become president of the American Medical Association. Exactly. He was a member of the New York Academy of Medicine. So this is a very conflicted legacy because presumably some of the things that he helped start or he helped invent are
在这段视频中，这位女性说，当我去医院时，尽管我很痛苦，但我还是确保自己盛装打扮，因为如果我盛装打扮，也许我会得到更好的治疗，而不被视为一个寻求毒品的人。所以在医学界如何看待黑人以及黑人身体方面，这种现象依然存在。不过，马里恩·西姆斯发现的一些东西今天仍在被使用或影响着现代医学实践，这也是事实。是的。他后来成为了美国医学会的主席。没错。他是纽约医学会的成员。所以这是一个充满冲突的遗产，因为大概他帮助开创或帮助发明的有些事情是
things that are of use to us today and we value and we benefit from that knowledge. And yet that knowledge was obtained at such great cost. It was obtained at great cost. And I recently read a 2011 study that was done by physicians. And they looked at medical textbooks to see how Sims was referred. He was referred as a father of modern gynecology, someone who perfected the surgical technique, but no discussion about his legacy in terms of conducting these experimental surgeries on enslaved women. So that's part of the problem. We can say that some of these surgeries that he did, women today are benefiting from,
我们今天能用到并且我们重视并从这些知识中受益的东西。然而，这些知识是以巨大的代价获得的。它是以巨大代价获得的。我最近读了一位医生在2011年做的一项研究。他们查阅了医学教科书，看看西姆斯是如何被提及的。他被称为现代妇科之父，一个完善了外科技术的人，但没有讨论他在对被奴役女性进行这些实验性手术方面的遗产。所以这就是问题的一部分。我们可以说，他做的其中一些手术，今天的女性正在从中受益，
especially in poor countries. But at the same time, we can't forget how that came to be. I'm wondering as someone who is a physician herself, what do you think should be done with those statues? It's one of those things where I'm conflicted. If you had asked me this question last spring spring I would have given you a different answer, and I'll tell you why I'm conflicted. Last summer, I went to Liverpool, and Liverpool has a remarkable international museum of slavery. And one of the things that I did when I was in Liverpool, I took a slavery history tour because Liverpool was at the center of the transatlantic
特别是在贫困国家。但与此同时，我们不能忘记这一切是如何实现的。作为一名医生，我想知道你认为应该如何处理这些雕像？这是让我感到矛盾的事情之一。如果你去年春天问我这个问题，我会给你一个不同的答案，我会告诉你为什么我感到矛盾。去年夏天，我去过利物浦，利物浦有一个非凡的国际奴隶制博物馆。我在利物浦时做的事情之一，就是参加了一次奴隶制历史之旅，因为利物浦是跨大西洋
slave trade. And on an art deco building, there was an image of Neptune since its Liverpool and water, and underneath Neptune there were two black children who were in chains. And the Torah guide, who was an 80 plus year old black gentleman, asked us, do you think this should be taken down? And most people say yes and he says I think it should stay and he said I think it should stay because I don't want people to forget it happened. And so I think that we need to do something to commemorate the women. To add something to say, yes, Sims did this, but what about Anna? What about Lucy, what about Betsy? I think if we don't do that, that people will forget what happened to those women. So, as a historian and as a teacher, I think that it's important for people to know what happened to those women. And if we whisk away these images of Sims, people will forget. How do you hear what these women were going through? So if you could speak to Anarka and Lucy and Betsy, what do you think they would tell you? I think
奴隶贸易的中心。在一座装饰风艺术风格的建筑上，有一个海神的形象，因为利物浦临水，在海神下方有两个戴着铁链的黑人儿童。导游是一位80多岁的黑人老绅士，他问我们，你们认为这应该被拆除吗？大多数人说是的，他说我认为它应该留下来，他说我认为它应该留下来，因为我不想让人们忘记它发生过。所以我认为我们需要做点什么来纪念这些女性。补充点什么来说，是的，西姆斯做了这件事，但安娜卡呢？露易丝呢，贝茨呢？我认为如果我们不这样做，人们就会忘记那些女性身上发生的事。因此，作为一名历史学家和老师，我认为让人们了解那些女性身上发生了什么很重要。如果我们把这些西姆斯的画像拿走，人们就会忘记。你是如何听到这些女性所经历的事情的？所以如果你能和安娜卡、露易丝以及贝茨对话，你认为她们会告诉你什么？我认为
I think the story they would tell me would not start with sims. I think the story they would tell me would be about their lives as enslaved women. It would begin there. It would begin how there were times where if that baby had survived, that the baby would have been taken away from them. They would talk to me about how as being black women their bodies were used sexually, that they did not have consent, and that what happened to them with Sims was part and parcel of what their lives were at that particular time. But I think the other thing they would want us to know is that they were human beings, and that they also deserve their story to be memorialized, that we have statues of Sims in Columbia, South Carolina, in New York City. There are portraits and medical schools of Sims. Where is their story? If you could build a memorial of Tu Anica, Betsy, and Lucy, or a memorial that stood alongside the memorials that we have erected to Marion Sims in South Carolina and New York City, what would the memorial say?
我认为她们告诉我的故事不会从西姆斯开始。我认为她们告诉我的故事会是关于她们作为被奴役女性的生活。它会从那里开始。它会从有时如果那个婴儿活下来，婴儿会被从她们身边夺走开始。她们会告诉我，作为黑人女性，她们的身体在性方面被利用，她们无法自主同意，而且西姆斯对她们做的事只是她们在那个特定时期生活的一部分。但我认为她们还想让我们知道的是，她们是人，她们的故事也值得被纪念，我们在南卡罗来纳州哥伦比亚市、在纽约市都有西姆斯的雕像。医学院里有西姆斯的肖像。她们的故事在哪里？如果你能为安娜卡、贝茨和露易丝建立一个纪念碑，或者一个与我们在南卡罗来纳州和纽约市为马里恩·西姆斯竖立的纪念碑并存的纪念碑，这个纪念碑会写些什么？
The statue would not be of the experiments, because I think that it's important not just to think of them as victims of these experiments. It might be with the three of them together, or it might be with their holding children that they were mothers, that they were women. So that's what part of it. So it would not be their and Lucy, the mothers of modern gynecology. In the woman, it is a checklist. Can you imagine anything worse than this?
这座雕像不会是关于实验的，因为我认为不仅要把她们看作这些实验的受害者，这一点很重要。它可能是她们三个人的合影，或者可能是她们抱着孩子的画面，表明她们是母亲，她们是女性。所以这是其中的一部分。所以它不会是她们和露易丝，现代妇科之母亲。在这个女性身上，这是一个清单。你能想象比这更糟糕的事吗？
If the answer is no, ask again. Bettina Judd is a professor of gender and women studies at the College of William & Mary. She's also a poet, and she recently wrote about a medical experience she had in a book called Patient, drawing not just on her personal history as a black woman, but the stories of Anika, Betsy, and Lucy. Produced a Maggie Penman spoke to Bettina Judd and asked her to read some of her poetry. In 2006, in her first year of graduate school,
如果答案是否定的，请再次询问。贝蒂娜·贾德是威廉玛丽学院的性别与妇女研究教授。她也是一位诗人，她最近在一本名为《病人》的书中写到了一次医疗经历，这不仅借鉴了她作为黑人女性的个人历史，还借鉴了安娜卡、贝茨和露易丝的故事。制作人玛吉·彭曼与贝蒂娜·贾德进行了交谈，并请她朗读了她的一些诗作。2006年，在她读研究生的第一年，
Bettina Judd had what she calls an ordeal with medicine. She was driving home from her part-time job and had to pull over because of a sharp pain in her abdomen. In 2006, I had an ordeal with medicine. I must have been found guilty of something. I don't feel innocent here lurking with ghosts. See? It happens like that.
贝蒂娜·贾德遭遇了她所谓的医疗磨难。她正开着车从兼职工作的地方回家，不得不把车停在路边，因为腹部一阵剧痛。2006年，我遭遇了一场医疗磨难。我一定是被判定犯了什么罪。在这里潜伏在鬼魂之中，我并不觉得自己是清白的。看？事情就是这样发生的。
I started a thought that is quite benign and ended up peckin' to baste. I had an ordeal with medicine and was found innocent or guilty. It feels the same because I live in a haunted house. A house can be a dynasty, a bloodline, a body. There was punishment, like the way the body is murdered by its own weight when lynched, not that I was wrong, but that verdicts come coming a bloodline. In 2006, I had an ordeal with medicine. To recover, I learned why ghosts come to me. The research question is, why am I patient? Bettina Judd had to be patient. As a doctor told her she was having menstrual cramps
我开始了一个相当温和的想法，结果却一团糟。我经历了一场医疗磨难，被判定无罪或有罪。感觉是一样的，因为我住在一间闹鬼的房子里。房子可以是一个王朝、一个血统、一个身体。有惩罚，就像身体在受绞刑时被自身的重量谋杀一样，不是我错了，而是判决顺着血统而来。2006年，我遭遇了一场医疗磨难。为了康复，我明白了为什么鬼魂会来找我。研究的问题是，为什么我是病人？贝蒂娜·贾德必须保持耐心。一位医生告诉她，她有痛经
and sent her home with painkillers. A few days later, she was told she had a bladder infection and given antibiotics. She was repeatedly given pregnancy tests, though she had told doctors she wasn't having sex with men. She didn't know it at the time, but what she was suffering from was an ovarian torsion, a rotation of the ovary that makes it impossible for blood to flow to it. She was experiencing the death of one of her organs. There might be something called an impatient. Pregnancy tests, doctors whispers, my week-long
并打发她带着止痛药回家。几天后，她被告知患有膀胱感染并获得了抗生素。她多次接受妊娠测试，尽管她曾告诉医生她没有和男性发生性关系。她当时并不知道，但她所患的是卵巢扭转，即卵巢旋转导致血液无法流向它。她正在经历她一个器官的死亡。可能有一种东西叫做不耐烦。妊娠测试，医生的耳语，我为期一周的
funk sterile lubricants discarded speculums. Everywhere of morphine mimics a familiar morning, speculums. Everywhere of morphine mimics a familiar morning, another dream of drowning in mucus, meeting a dead ovary. She floats in yellow, spits ovum into the poison, wrinkles, black, and mourning. Throughout this ordeal, Bettina kept thinking about an article she had read not long before she became ill, about J. Marion Sims, who operated on slave women in the 1840s. Annarka, Betsy, and Lucy began to haunt her morphine-fueled dreams. She tried to understand what was happening to her through their stories. Nurses ask me how much does it hurt on a scale from one to ten? Annarka, Westcott, Betsy Harris, and Lucy Zimmerman are taken into the care of her electing
抑郁，无菌润滑剂，丢弃的窥器。到处都是吗啡，模仿着熟悉的早晨，窥器。到处都是吗啡，模仿着熟悉的早晨，另一个在粘液中溺水的梦，遇到一个死去的卵巢。她漂浮在黄色中，把卵子吐进毒药里，皱缩，黑暗，哀悼。在这场磨难中，贝蒂娜一直想着一篇文章，那是她在生病不久前读到的，关于J·马里恩·西姆斯的文章，他在19世纪40年代对女奴进行了手术。安娜卡、贝茨和露易丝开始萦绕在她由吗啡驱动的梦境中。她试图通过她们的故事来理解自己身上发生了什么。护士问我，在一到十的范围内有多痛？安娜卡、韦斯特科特、贝茨·哈里斯和露易丝·齐默尔曼被交由她选举产生的
country surgeon in Montgomery, Alabama. See blood on a white hospital sheet? Tell me I'm having menstrual cramps, Betsy's first birth. Send me home with oxycodone, ibupofin, Lucy months out of household duties. After five hours in triage, Anarkca, his first Viseko vaginal fishtula, and another prescription. In these three, Sims shapes his speculum and vents his silver sutures, perfect protocol for proper handling of the female pelvis. We wake. Unannesticized or addicted to Obyan children born children disappeared helpless
乡村外科医生照顾，地点在阿拉巴马州蒙哥马利。看到白色医院床单上有血？告诉我我有痛经，贝茨的第一胎。打发我带着羟考酮、布洛芬回家，露易丝离开家务几个月。在分诊台呆了五个小时后，安娜卡，他的第一个膀胱阴道瘘患者，以及另一张处方。在这三个人身上，西姆斯塑造了他的窥器并摆弄他的银质缝合线，这是妥善处理女性骨盆的完美方案。我们醒来。未经麻醉或对阿片类药物成瘾，出生的孩子，消失的孩子，无助的
help she kept being asked this question what is your pain on a scale from 1 to 10 and she would ask herself well what is 1 what is 10 if I say it's a 10 what will they think they'll see me a young African-American woman alone. Will they think I'm looking for pain pills? I'll give it a seven. Betsy invents the speck of them fall 1845. Introducing the bent handle of the spoon, I saw everything as no man had ever seen before, from the story of my life by J. Marion Sins. I have been to another way to open the body, make space. More pliable than pewter, my skin may be less giving.
帮助她一直被问到这个问题，在一到十的范围内，你的疼痛程度是多少？她会问自己，嗯，什么是1，什么是10？如果我说这是10，她们会怎么想？她们会把我当成一个孤身一人的年轻非洲裔美国女性。她们会以为我在找止痛药吗？我给它打七分。贝茨发明了窥器，1845年秋。引入勺子的弯曲手柄，我看到了一切，这是前无古人见过的，摘自《J·马里恩·西姆斯生平》。我找到了另一种打开身体、腾出空间的方法。比白镴更柔韧，我的皮肤可能没那么有弹性。
Great discoveries are made on cushioned lessons and hardfalls. Sims invents the speculum. I invent the wind sing. If you must of it, the looking away, the hear or discovery. Finally, Bettina ended up in a third hospital, this time a teaching hospital in an African-American neighborhood in her hometown. One day after multiple pelvic exams, after questions about her sexual history, after her answer is not being believed, she had a moment of outburst.
伟大的发现在舒适的教训和艰难的跌倒中诞生。西姆斯发明了窥器。我发明了风歌。如果你必须这样做，移开视线，听到或发现。最后，贝蒂娜来到第三家医院，这一次是她家乡的一个非洲裔美国人社区的教学医院。有一天，在经历了多次骨盆检查、关于她性生活史的询问、她的回答不被信任之后，她爆发了。
She sat allowed in a room full of doctors. Gynecology was built on the backs of black women anyway. To the patient. Tears will only leave you wanting for water and more time. Which, as you know, will be spent waiting. It's been 10 years since Bettina Jad had her ordeal with medicine. Next week she'll be in Columbia, South Carolina, and she's going to see the Statue of Sims, which she says she hopes will stay up for now.
她在一个满是医生的房间里大声说出来。妇科本来就是建立在黑人女性的背上的。对病人来说。眼泪只会让你渴望水和更多时间。如你所知，这些时间都将花在等待上。距离贝蒂娜·贾德遭遇医疗磨难已经过去10年了。下周她将前往南卡罗来纳州哥伦比亚，她将去看西姆斯的雕像，她说她希望这座雕像暂时能留下来。
Until we have a conversation about who Sims was and who the women he operated on were. Until there's a statue of Ann Arca, Lucy, and Betsy, the mothers of Gynecology. A statue she says that she hopes will be bigger than the statue of Sims. Produce a Maggie Penman and Bettina Gi. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
直到我们开始对话，讨论西姆斯是谁，他做过手术的女性又是谁。直到有一座安娜卡、露易丝和贝茨的雕像，妇科之母们的雕像。她说她希望这座雕像能比西姆斯的雕像更大。制作人玛吉·彭曼和贝蒂娜·吉。你 这个剧集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子来留下评论。